ladies and gentlemen the joke doctor mr
cherry corley yeah hey look at that see
i love how the big face just comes in
there so it's like
there we go ahead look at that now
you're the now you're the head of the
pack now this is i am so jazzed about
this one i mean like there's so much as
jerry says synergy between the hot
breath the verse and what he's doing and
so many
people
are in both worlds and it's just it's
it's all about positivity and being
supportive in people's comedies journeys
so it's only right that you're our our
headliner of this pro talk
oh that's such a such an honor man to be
part of this first of all it's a
community you formed such a cool
community you give it a nickname hot
breath and it's like most comics they
try to you know hide their breath
because it's like we're basically coffee
and alcohol it's like anybody smells
this bread they're gonna pass out and
it's like but you're like hot breath
let's put it on people we're all hot
breath and it's like first of all
awesome right and it's like when i first
met you at the world series of comedy
you were doing a podcast seminar and
then we got to chat afterwards and i
liked what you were doing there i go
this guy really gives a [ __ ] look at
this this is like cool right it's you're
not just there for yourself and it's
like that's why you know you do
festivals and [ __ ] you don't just do it
to win you do it to build that network
of of like-minded people and build
relationships
nothing is done in this business without
relationships then we talked about
afterwards we did our interview that
wound up going like two hours and 10
minutes or something like that it was
like two hours yeah it was just like so
much fun the time just flew by and now
um
um and then
then we were like every now and when
during the when the pandemic hit i moved
had to move everything online and then i
was doing i said what can i do to help
out uh and i did like these i do these a
la carte classes and we started them at
like 25 bucks a class
just to make it affordable for people to
keep going back to something to keep
doing their thing and give out like a
three hour class
and then uh that was going well and
every every time we'd mention hot breath
and check out joel buyers uh the right
ten club it's like you want to account
have accountability go to the right 10
club and it's like people are like oh
okay and they're writing that down and
it's like does it take away from me no
because i just gave them a value point
exactly right and they're like oh that's
great information they go check you out
they go hey this guy really loves what
he's doing there's like and then there's
but and then bo i remember bo started
putting heaps when i got this the second
interview arranged right on twitter and
yeah back in august man you were like
when you said you said this at the
beginning you're like oh you're like the
the wind beneath my wings so it's like
yeah he's like
he's like the the engines that fly the
plane you know
and it's been amazing like when you talk
about community is just like giving
comics a safe space to try and do things
and experiment
it's just giving people the opportunity
to like fail upward like try it out
because and we'll laugh when you fail
because we're laughing at ourselves too
yeah man i did that
so sometimes in my classes when somebody
like bombs a joke and it sits there i
laugh because i'm like oh i know i've
been there right and then so they feel
because you laugh like now what do you
do with your friends that exact thing if
your friend fails you're gonna laugh at
it right if i got all protective
people be like
okay this makes me even feel more
nervous but if you laugh and make it
okay people are like all right all right
we can risk here and nobody's gonna
judge us they're just gonna laugh with
us
and then hit and then you laugh and then
give them a fix
for the joke and it's like oh here's
what's missing what are you trying to
say with that joke i'm trying to say
this oh well why don't you put this and
you're missing a connector put this in
that'll tie those two together and also
they're like boom the joke works
and they go how'd you do that
that's why i'm the joke doctor no i know
i didn't even name myself the joke
doctor somebody else did some old
veteran he was like man you make jokes
well you're the joke doctor we were
gonna throw those jokes out and you just
like hey what if you did this
i'm curious like as someone like i've
been doing like coaching with comics and
like workshops and stuff i'm curious how
did you come up with like your
terminology like how
like i can explain to people like
here's how this joke could be better but
like there's i don't have like a
tangible way of like describing it in
terms or like a system you know like how
did you develop a system to like clearly
communicate a process well two things
happen that uh first of all when i met
george carlin way back in the day um it
was a crazy
coincidental meeting he actually gave me
a ride to the airport uh in his car that
had picked him up and i had just
finished my i want to i did a corporate
my one of my first corporates in new
york city and i was waiting for my car
and it was late and then uh he was there
and he hey you uh you need a ride and i
was like that guy looks like george
garland and i said oh well if it's not
an imposition you go to the airport
right jfk i said yes sir he says ride
with me
okay so i get in there he goes my name's
george i'm like oh [ __ ] it is
and uh you know so we rode to the
airport it turns out his his agent had
recommended that he watch my dad who's a
character actor at the time so that he
can learn to be a better character actor
and then they had the same agent and we
started the conversation and then um uh
kind of he just said hey anytime you uh
see me come say hello if you see me
somewhere and i did and we wound up
talking and one of the things he said
was um
um you know he said that i know with 98
accuracy that the joke is funny before i
step on stage and i said how do you know
that he said because it contains all the
necessary elements for a joke to be
funny and i was like what are those
elements and he says you're going to
have to learn those on your own kid
and then after a glass of wine and a
painkiller which was his drug of choice
at the time he said i think the reason i
say that is because
intuitively i know what they are
but i can't verbalize it yeah that'll be
your job you do that yeah and you can
tell everybody how it works and so i
took it as a command it was an order
that's an order so i said i've got to do
this george said i got to do this so
um i started to look around and do some
research and
the first set of uh you know sort of the
ideas and the and the labels that came
across was from melvin helitzer who
wrote a book called comedy writing
secrets
now melvin it was a journalism professor
at ohio university and he used to do a
humor class where he had a like a
two-year waiting list
and um and so in that book he had some
basic labels and so i started work off
of those labels and i said well this one
works but that for me but this one
doesn't now the thing is he's a
journalism professor and he put a piece
and what i realized is his book was
built off of
a gene parrot's book
joke writing step by step jean parra was
bob hope's head writer and so uh but i
had studied with gene parrott for two
years and
after i read melvin's book and that's
what got me my job on the tonight show
so
uh writing for jay
but those labels help you to keep things
keep track of things and they help you
to um
when you're going back through your
material you go okay the nine elements
that uh psychological laughter triggers
i wound up coming back with were
surprise superiority embarrassment
recognition incongruity ambulance
configuration and coincidence i added
coincidence late because i was like it's
even bigger than surprise it's one of
those where you go oh [ __ ] i never
thought about it that way
that's that coincidence and sometimes if
you do an analogy like you do an analogy
and say my ex-wife she was an alcoholic
she was sort of like a smartphone at any
given point i could usually find her at
at least one bar
if people go oh [ __ ] yeah never thought
about it that way that's so true
and it's like that is a coincidence that
that to those two dissimilar ideas were
actually similar so we're actually
laughing at that coincidence plus we
recognize those two elements and you put
them on a hook with an illogical
equation of my ex-wife was like a
smartphone huh
solve that for us show us how that's
true
and when you say that you watch an
audience any comedian says an analogy to
an audience like that they sit up and
they're like they get focused they're
like oh wait what how
and then you solve it for them first of
all you release that tension because you
solve that neurologically illogical
equation then you solve it with the
nuance that oh [ __ ] that matches and
they go what a wow what a coincidence
you know yeah that's seeing that like
when i give people feedback i'll be like
they some people will set up an analogy
and then never deliver on it as well
like they they they're in there but they
don't build on it you know so i can be
like oh you set up an analogy there now
you could use a venn diagram to compare
and contrast and find the parallels but
i don't have like a
use this catchy phrase you know like i
don't i mean maybe i don't need to i'm
just i was just thinking about that as i
was looking at how effective you're
teaching it and why so many people
in the hot breath of verse take value in
it and take advantage of all your
courses and book and everything is i was
like he communicates it so clearly it's
like i can tell people through that like
description oh i see an analogy there
you could use a venn diagram but i don't
have like a
used blue
you know but maybe i don't well you know
sometimes when
as you like it's like music right when
you learn first learn music
and when you're first learning you're uh
playing guitar you're playing your ski
you learn your scales and then from your
scales you learn chord shapes and then
from those chord shapes you learn power
chords oh that sounds kind of cool and
then you learn these interesting chord
shapes that give you a more percussive
sound and then you learn you know you
learn how to do do the the the the
stroke that's a shuffle stroke that
gives you that little crisp sort of like
you know and it sounds cool sounds
cooler now i'm sounding like some of the
people i've actually heard play and then
as you're learning more and you start
developing your style you go back and
use these other ones just almost
automatically and then the hammer on you
know is that is like a it gives it a
different texture and so as you're
learning these things
before when you first started scales you
didn't know what the uh i did my own
radio edit there did you see that i went
you don't know
you didn't know what the hell a uh a
hammer on was but now that you know it
now it's not it's like buying a car you
didn't see that car before then you
bought the car and you see that car
everywhere so now you have the hammer on
you know you could use it so when you
know a reverse is there you played with
the reverse you've learned to write a
reverse you know you could take a
sentence if you're writing story based
comedy just put the story on the page
first then go line by line and find some
of the humor in each of the lines like
you say the line does it is there an
assumption an expectation or an image i
can shatter is there two dissimilar
ideas converging before i could do an
incongruity joke or an associative joke
is there uh are there is there some word
play so those are the first three
questions i would ask and then you could
go on from there and go is there some
irony present is there paradox you know
so
once you have those tools in your sort
of bag of tricks you can take any
logical grouping of words pretty much
and make it funny
okay yeah i mean i i really just push
people
to get like personal and i'm like what
jokes could you write that no one else
could create you know like what wouldn't
be like a fortune cookie or a popsicle
joke so i'm always pushing people to get
more personal
so i mean everyone has different styles
i just see how effective your way and
we'll get to your questions too i'm like
selfishly like how do i help communicate
more clearly jerry um but i guess i
guess it's working if people get results
from it i guess i'm just thinking of how
can there be a clever system or
something you know there is a there is a
couple of clever systems like that one i
in one of my first videos i put out was
uh called joke writing one two three
like it's just getting started where do
i even get the ideas hey where do i
where to get the ideas to write
something funny stop writing something
funny stop trying to think of something
funny just write something and then make
it funny yes
once you have it on the page you can
control it i remember there's one dude
he sold the course and uh bless his
heart he used to be like uh he goes uh
and he was from kentucky right and he
was like he was like you know you know
you know the you know the easiest way to
stop being funny that's how we talked
i'm not making this is exactly his voice
i practiced it he's like he goes you
know how to the easiest way to not be
funny write your material
because if you write it it's on a page
it's one dimensional
wow it's like that's stupid yeah it's
like you then you're removing the
element of how important the craft is
right every script in hollywood is one
dimensional
i dare you to call tom hanks a
one-dimensional actor right it's like no
he's
you take those words and all of a sudden
matt mcconaughey and that thing he did
on wolf of wall street he was in the
beginning part only at like a couple of
scenes and he was nominated for an oscar
because he took that little simple role
and just listen give it this all this
nuance and crazy matt mcconaughey [ __ ]
you know and uh so that's that's your
craft now you have to bring it on stage
and communicate it in a way by being
completely present with the audience and
then all of a sudden that joke evolves
from a joke to an experience
because that's like the second or third
draft you write it on the page that's
one draft you put it up on the stage
that evolves into a whole nother draft
of a joke
you know because now you're looking at
the audience they're nodding so you're
communicating with them and then you're
responding off of what they you know
what they think of what's their what are
they thinking i'm going to respond off
their their response and it's non-verbal
it's just like ha ha you know oh yeah
and then such and such happens that's a
tag or a topper you know when you add
the act out i know it seems like i'm on
cocaine but i just have a nose hair
that's itching me
i just we talk about this i just get
jacked up that's all there is to it hey
that's a that's a great that's a great
problem to have so with new comedians
since the last time we've talked we've
actually had a lot of new comedians um
new to the game join the group so what
advice do you give to any new comedian
that's just getting started okay so one
of the things is uh um
check out the videos right check out the
uh the youtube videos because i give
away a lot of [ __ ] i'm gonna go getting
back to doing more videos too so i've
been away from that for a little while
um just moving everything online got
kind of overwhelming
and it's just you know me and my
assistant and that's it you know i don't
have a crew like you got a crew right
you got you got bo he handles everything
this guy look at look at this look at
the shoulders on this he's the heavy
lifter you know you joe you got dress
shirts on you're like uh don't get my
hands dirty i've got [ __ ] to do
my part is perfect my hair [ __ ] you in
your hair
right it's like you got hair you're just
jealous of hair yeah that's him
jealousy with him but
but here's the advice check out the
videos right that's a start then what i
would do is
just write sentences write facts about
you
just facts about me one dude in my class
wrote lazy one word yeah obviously you
wrote one [ __ ] word but it's like you
know but what if we add an element to
that what if we add a descriptor to lazy
lazy at what who what where why when and
how you know the the you know that's the
maxim of the five w's sort of asking
questions who what where why when and
how lazy it what what would be really
embarrassing embarrassment as a laughter
trigger to be lazy at
that's the question for you
jill or
bo
what would be embarrassing to be lazy
yet really embarrassing to be lazy
sex
absolutely right i'm a lazy lover
all of a sudden that statement takes on
a whole new flare doesn't it it's no
longer i'm lazy i'm lazy at sex i'm a
lazy lover so if you're lazy you love
her
in bed it's sex what uh who where why
when and how positions what would be
your favorite position if you're lazy at
sex a nap
right
my favorite so i'm a dude anybody a
lover here you guys good lovers you
think he's a good lover right now it's
like i'm a lazy lover like my favorite
position is a nap
you know now you have a quick joke and
it's just from a fact about you you can
even build that out even farther
by asking more questions what else is in
sex what else is in sex that it's like
you know i when i masturbate i'm like
it's just not worth it
you know now you have a joke that comes
out of that right so it's not even it's
not even uh you know it's just what
happens when you're what how do you
respond to stuff when you're lazy it's
like you like you don't even if you're
really tired or you're lazy you don't
even wanna
i gotta pee but i'm not gonna get out of
bed right now i'm just gonna go to sleep
maybe i'll still hold it throughout the
night sullivan said childbirth
hell yeah that's funny
that's so funny oh god
hilarious that's that's nothing actually
has me thinking like wait a minute
that's possible
yeah lazy yeah that's why they give two
c-sections
ah or lazy
she can't she she yeah lazy section so
they don't even call them c sections
sections yeah it's like because it's
like she's not pushing she doesn't know
how to push she's not pushing she
doesn't want to push she's not going to
push the baby out in time we got to get
the baby out all right we're going to
have to section her all of a sudden and
it turns into an operating room and they
cut her open and take out a baby i know
i've seen two of them i have five kids
did i tell you guys that wow because i'm
only half mormon yeah
you have five kids
five kids from two different moms
i'm sorry three different moms you're
like johnny appleseed out here
he doesn't even look like he's in the
nba right
by the time i say that people groan i go
what what happened somebody goes oh
that's racist i go why you said nba
it goes so how's that racist
and then i let them configure it and
they go well uh because um uh you see
black people are who's making the
stereotypes now so really you're gonna
jump to me being racist and you're the
one generalizing yeah
i love putting people in that trap that
pc trap
five more kids he gets a parent badge
that's right you know my dad had six so
i'm trying to reach that goal
goodness
my father like son
so when people start
start writing facts about you that's one
way now remember george carl and jerry
seinfeld didn't do anything about
themselves
everything was outside of themselves so
if you're afraid because when i started
every i was doing observational stuff
because george said to me take the [ __ ]
that drives you crazy make it funny
and i was like oh yeah then there's a
catharsis because you ever watch the
newspaper you read the newspaper watch
tv and you call [ __ ] when you're
watching the news or something i go all
the time he goes make those your jokes
he said but make him funny and not the
trick he gave me was
he's like raise the bridge
if you raise the eyebrows you can't be
mad
it's got to be absurd or ridiculous or
confusing right
john stewart used to use that all the
time you'd be like what's going on why
and so it made it more palatable for
people to listen to even like the real
sensitive kind of tension the divisive
uh subject matters because you were
asking questions about it it's like bill
burr somebody explain it doesn't make
any sense somebody explained this to me
how does this work
so even though he's very strongly
committed emotionally to his material
and he's ranting about it he's very
focused on his point of view it's still
all based in
i can't figure somebody explain it
doesn't make any sense
and that's how he walks through and
that's how he was able to walk that line
of being firmly committed to something
that may seem misogynistic or you know
sometimes even sexist
really bill bird no tell me it's not
true and i love bilderberg but he
doesn't sometimes he doesn't even know
he's sexist you know
i mean and that's kind of an interesting
thing that you you brought that up
because we were having that discussion
last night is sometimes it's not the
joke that's the problem it's the look
you give
like that one little look can probably
make or break your joke or probably yeah
you convey something through your
emotion as well right
so in there in my book i have this thing
called the the teaser formula which i
stole directly from melvin helitzer but
i changed a little bit based on my
experience as a stand-up
you know his experience was as a
journalism professor trying to convey
this in a communicative way to people on
how to write humor and mine was taking
those that the core ideas i got from him
and from gene parrott and then going up
on stage and gene was a writer right it
wasn't a stand-up
then i was on the road 43 weeks out of
the year
and every night i was in front of an
audience i'd have a hypothesis or i have
an idea i want to try in front of an
audience try that out try that and then
i'd listen to the audio later and write
the notes on it on how it worked so
that's kind of i was using the comedy
clubs as my lab
so
and every night i put the earpods on
listen to the audio write the notes and
it was like sort of like so the audience
even know they were my guinea pigs so
trying this stuff i mean i was having
fun with them but at the same time i
realized wait a second
the joke is only half of it then there's
the teaser formula you know t-e-a-s-e-r
target you have to know what you're
making fun of you have to have a
specific target sometimes that's what's
lacking we're not sure what we're making
the joke about is a joke about a concept
it's about a person is it about an
entity is it about you know this
magazine article is it about the
psychologist who had said something
ridiculous you know a lot of times we'll
just do this bland thing and go like
well who are we making fun of here
what's what's so and then the second
thing is like so so target know what
you're making fun of right and so and
and you know sometimes as we write the
joke we don't know exactly who we're
making fun of and then we go oh this is
not about the president this is about
the congress or this is about the law or
this is about racism or this is about
you know immigration
or the decisions made or whatever but we
got to know who we talk where the
audience has to know who we're talking
about so that's target and then there's
emotion
this is where so many comics fail
is you said the facial expression the
facial expression isn't just a facial
expression it comes from
an inspiration or motivation or a moment
right this is why i learned so much
about acting
in standup i remember doing my in acting
class i took you know i studied at
uh the juilliard uh acting a summer
acting program um for years and then i
was at the actor's studio and then at
least rosberg theater institute and one
of my favorite instructors i loved her
because she would break through all my
[ __ ]
defense mechanisms my tricks
it's like she goes oh jerry so you're
doing stand-up that's so great could you
do five minutes for the class and i go
yeah i'm gonna knock this out of the
park watch this [ __ ] right because i
write great comedy i i'm i'm good with
my words you know i have the best words
the best words
i get up on i get up on the stage and i
do the jokes for the five minutes and i
know the jokes are good the audience is
live the class is laughing they're like
yeah right good jokes
my teacher sits there with her arms
folded
her legs crossed and she says oh look
jerry thinks his jokes are so clever he
doesn't need to perform them
and i went
what do you mean by that because my dad
brilliant he was my coach too he used to
anytime i filibustered him because i
hated be wrong man i didn't i needed to
be perfect in front of my dad and i'd
always be oh yeah yeah yeah i i got it i
got it whatever yeah i got i got what
you're saying and he said son anytime i
give you a note i want you to follow it
up with two questions
yeah yeah got it yeah i totally got it
two questions got it got oh [ __ ] that
means i have to listen to the note
right you know these we we we're
sometimes those people we don't want to
be seen as flawed right so but our
students do this all the time they'll
like jump on it oh yeah yeah i totally
oh yeah i know i know what you're
talking about they don't really want to
listen and acknowledge that they made a
mistake but then you learn that mistakes
are gold
so it'd be like no one might see someone
teacher said oh look jerry thinks his
jokes are so clever he doesn't need to
perform them
i was like oh what do you mean by that
and how can i improve that
now it's no longer a critique it's a
collaboration
you're collaborating you're creating
together now because he'll now he'll
give you a follow-up and then it's like
oh yeah oh i see it and maybe he hits
that one note that flips the switch and
makes you go
how come i didn't see that before oh
yeah yeah yeah i got it now i got it now
go away i got it i got that you flip the
switch right
and so she said take the same five
minutes go home
write down your emotional through lines
for each of those jokes what are you
trying to say what you're expressing
and respond to each joke
now what i learned was watch friends
the the television show
the reason it got so many laughs was the
directors and the editors along with
this terrific ensemble and the terrific
writing
they knew that the jokes the laughs
didn't just come on the joke it came on
the reactions to the joke
where you had the other people react and
they react off the reaction
so in stand-up we are our own reaction
shot
so they have the other angle get joey's
reaction to that joke
and that's the second laugh and then
phoebe's reaction to the joke that's a
third laugh but on stage we are joey we
are phoebe
so we're reacting how did he say that i
don't know why he said that is that
weird
that kind of thing so we have all these
inspirations that come the facial
expressions happen as a result of some
emotion
and we all have these emotions when
we're in a conversation at a party
so it's like you don't have to make up
[ __ ] it's all right there sometimes in
the mechanics you can build in a deadpan
like you want to give them something
just sit there
like um you know you have something
configurational just stare at them for a
moment
you know and just wait for them to
respond but um so that emotion that that
that that that mechanical look that
comes from some sort of
like when uh esther hearst she's like in
her 70s she does like she goes dating at
my age is hard because my men aren't
she scans across the room at very
jonathan winters right and she gets a
huge laugh it's a what a difference in
the left she does it without that little
slow burn
she doesn't get as big a left she does
that slow burn applause break you know
so it really does because that sort of
conveys her emotion can you believe that
[ __ ] you know
all these guys with ed it's like all i
want to do is [ __ ]
yes slowing down is such an important
like thing comics struggle with
especially early on because that's
people think you got to get all the
jokes out but really slowing down that
timing that pacing is where a lot of the
humor comes from
that patience
breathe
and listen to
what their response is yes and then you
can respond off their response yep
yep but like if i was just doing that
what's that joe it's almost like you
gotta know the jokes so you're not in
your head like what's next what am i
thinking what are the next words knowing
the jokes will free you up to listen as
well
yes absolutely when you know the jokes
then you're not so worried you're not in
your head anymore you're present with
the audience like you know and it's like
you say a joke it's like what are they
thinking a lot of times when i write a
joke i'll write the joke with what the
response might be if it was a
conversation and then i wonder that's
where the tags and toppers come from oh
interesting and i think we have people
asking questions what was the rest of
the teaser thing you said
e a a stands for antagonism that's where
the kind of the jokes come from you are
antagonized in some way it doesn't mean
angered it means you're confused by
something curious about something what
is it with bugs you know that's jerry
seinfeld's antagonism you know um you
know uh bill byrd talking about like you
know divorce or this is ridiculous like
are women's really women are always
right i don't think so right so that
that annoyed him so he spoke on that and
it's like so what take the [ __ ] that
drives you crazy make it funny right or
take the [ __ ] that confuses you makes
you funny take the [ __ ] that that sounds
hypocritical make it funny or that
sounds uh that's ridiculous or you know
um
or you know surprises you you know or a
lot of times i'll just sit there because
i know sometimes the structure i can
just write a joke off a structure it's
like yesterday was my wife's birthday
for her birthday i got her a gift
certificate
for his and her massage
and she said jerry
this is a wii gift not a me gift so i
returned it and got her a gift
certificate for dinner for one
[Music]
i know i can utilize the paired phrase
to heighten the expectation and get a
left
so it's like knowing the mechanics and
what you can use
is like knowing what notes to play in a
certain chord progression you know uh
and that's part of the that's that's
part of the evolution of your mastery of
the comedy is like knowing what works
why it works i remember was coaching
some guy i think he's like he came to me
through you joel and uh every time i say
joel and i said embo joel
sounds like
it sounds like mattel's little hey we
need to extend the barbie line we've got
ken we need a joel and oh
and it's like what cars do they drive
you know
we're very progressive couple though
so matt had a question and it was a
really great question and it was like he
talked about something that happened
back in the sixth grade let me finish
that thing so
tea target emotion antagonism surprise
and then the last two are very important
you know it's exaggeration and realism
those two work together comedy is
heightened reality it's not necessarily
complete
on implausible absurdity because then we
go that would never happen
you know you can build to that
like you know when dennis wolfberg talks
about his wife having a baby and the
baby comes out but then it's not just
the baby that comes out it's
[Music]
all there's stuff right it's like it's
just a placenta it's like it's in there
so like it's blood and there's a
big huge baby comes out in this placenta
and there's blood and there's another
tricycle right and it's like in his
crazy he's so like wow what's coming out
of there a tricycle now makes sense to
him because he's built up the uh he's
like
this is crazy yeah and we accept the
tricycle as we suspend our disbelief and
accept the tricycle
so the intake antagonism that's kind of
like what some people would say would be
the um attitude
inspiration it's where the joke is from
you're driving around you see something
you go
authentic chinese cuisine say habla
espanol what
how do they speak in spanish if it's
authentic chinese
right it's like i'll have the chicken
chow mein with the dirty sanchez can i
get them
dirty sanchez you know so that's what
you see something sometimes and that and
inspires you or confuses you or
antagonizes you to write it down and say
i gotta talk about this this has
affected me emotionally
so the
emotion is where your angle comes from
your attitude or your point of view it's
like how do i feel about this it's like
like if i'm like a writer and i'm just
go to my editor and say i want to write
a story on the homeless they're going to
say what's the angle
and you're going to be like oh man
they're they're crapping up the
neighborhood with their rvs and their
garbage that's one angle you know my
heart i'm a bleeding heart liberal i
want to take care of everybody you know
this way i was raised i'd be like well
i'd feel so bad for them because so many
of them have been priced out of their
homes because the rental prices here in
l.a are ridiculous
right the rental is going through the
roof but nobody's getting no salaries
are going through the roof
we got to remedy that and so that's the
angle so that's a whole different angle
from the first angle
so it's like what am i trying to say and
what's my angle that refines
your comedy and makes now you're really
communicating and touching the audience
because you're sharing an angle
it's like uh like bill burr with the
joke he did about um
divorce settlements you know tiger woods
wife getting 250 250 million dollars
she's getting a quarter of a billion
she's a babysitter getting a quarter of
a [ __ ] billion dollars we know what
his angle is this is ridiculous these
settlements yeah but you know what i'm
saying so he sometimes he just says it
these settlements are ridiculous
so that's his through line on that
particular joke that's his point of view
so does the emotion always need to be
like a negative
no no okay i can delight my
my nine-year-old daughter is like you
see you we're driving we're you know
driving into a school right and we i
like to play the radio we like to listen
to music sometimes dance sort of get
warmed up for school and uh so we'll
play them but then they go to the
commercial
and sometimes they their this erectile
dysfunction commercial came on
and uh it's like they can get pretty
graphic
so it's like my daughter doesn't need to
listen to this
and two seconds later my daughter's like
dad turn that back up there might be
some important information there for me
i have reptiles
when that happened i pulled over
and i took an extra five minutes to
write that joke down
even if she was late for school the
joke's most important and it's like when
your comic that gets it i've lost a
couple of marriages because of being so
into comedy i remember one time i was
with this woman for a while and she goes
jerry every night you seem to get up on
stage and do comedy but tonight you
can't get it up for me and i was like
hold on i gotta write that down
because the joke's more important than i
just love how nonchalant i've lost a
couple marriages for how much i love
comedy like just not like that that that
happens right guys
comedy defines me
right and if i can't be me then i'm not
gonna be good for her and she's not
going to be good for me
and to think joel gets in trouble for
just doing a simple dab in front of his
wife my wife abhors when i do this it's
like and she said it's because it makes
me happy so i think it's a good marriage
she's my my wife recently said to me
when and when we first met she was like
oh my parents best friends are going to
come see you at a comedy club because
they hadn't her parents hadn't met me
yet yeah and they were like um it was
before when we were just dating she
because my parents best friends are
going to come see you perform i was at
harvey's in portland and she goes um i
go do you want me to change anything and
she was like you better not
no now that we've been married 14 years
she's like i don't like you making jokes
about me anymore
and i was like so my wife doesn't like
me make jokes about her so now i have a
girlfriend
so it could be either i have a
girlfriend or
these girlfriend jokes are really wife
jokes
hilarious you know so
my question was from mike mike
i am trying to write a joke from a grade
school experience in the early 60s how
do i overcome references that
millennials and ex-gins don't know i
like this because i've even made jokes
about growing up in the 80s and 90s that
people these days just
goes right over their head without a
doubt that happens
all the time i did a fundraiser for a
soccer team a 15 year old 16 year old
girls
and um you know it was over at flappers
they said hey jerry you can do this
fundraiser and keep it clean and i said
sure it's a 15 16 year old soccer player
girls and i was like
they're not going to get some of these
references they're just not going to get
them so i did my jokes about soccer
and uh for those gals and in this case
when you're talking about your childhood
it's about you right you're growing up
in sixth grade and um that happened like
uh
um several years ago when the
millennials lose them then part of the
joke to part of the jokes on the way to
the jokes is making fun of the
reminding these millennials about these
phrases or these things like uh you know
it's back in the back of the day so we
took the coke counter
and took the tab and threw it away that
back in the day when we had cokes with
tabs
and it's like you almost like like
gilbert godfrey used to do this and he
would basically take a moment to explain
the joke
and that became the gag on the way to
the big joke right so it'd be like um
you know so i remember uh i remember
this by johnny carson johnny carson he
was a guy who had a talk show for about
30 years
right like they should know this
you know especially your comics you're
in the business you're not doing your
homework you don't know johnny carson
so that's what mike would like still
make the reference but then almost make
a joke to the people that may not get
the reference type yeah cop pulled me
over and it's like you know he said you
know it's like he says what he got in a
got in the car i said uh you know i got
this battle jack daniels under the seat
and reefer in the glove box he arrested
me immediately for referring to weed as
reefer
right
because that's old school get out the
car
yeah that's yeah that's a good tip so
it's not like don't edit your joke just
actually find a new laugh based on
making that reference and this might
help you find a character through line
i'm old school
yeah and then you do an exercise top 10
reasons you know you're old school
and you we know the top 10
sort of uh because it was david
letterman's bag right and was david
levin's the most famous segment in late
night tv was the top 10 list yeah which
is so interesting because really it was
an exercise that writers used in
writer's rooms for finding punch lines
top 10 reasons you know your
mother-in-law hates you top 10 reasons
you know you're balding top 10 reasons
you know you know you're suffering from
ed top 10 reasons you know you're a lazy
lover
so now that helps you generate punch
lines so as you say these
you're taking the grabbing these punch
lines and then what you do is you hide
the top ten list and you take top three
of those or top four of those and
finesse them into a story now you have
these punch lines to go about how come
you're the why you're the old school guy
you know because i'm old school and you
can go on with this and then do it use
another punch line and write finesse the
context around it and say because i'm
old school and it's like now you've got
a whole character through line of
your old school
and then when people see you they can
identify you with something like oh this
dude he's um he's uh [ __ ] i don't know
his name but he's old school right and
now you've already branded yourself
that's what i'm like i'm currently like
as as i've been i've been doing this 11
years now and i released a comedy
special last year called the trophy
husband and i was like
this is the brand and then in hindsight
i'm like i don't know if i really want
to lean into that also because my wife
doesn't like me what we refer to my wife
is caramel here in the hot breath of her
so she doesn't nice
but um she doesn't really want me i
don't know i i'm leaving her out of it
so i'm looking for like
what is
how how can i figure out like how do i
come off to people what kind of funny
what kind of filter can i put my
material through and it's like and i
haven't figured it out yet i'm thinking
my i'm over optimistic am i almost grown
up like i look 13 but i'm 33 like i'm
i'm the vice principal
is it but is that my that's my whole act
i'm a vice principal no it's like no no
almost like you're that's you're the
kind of the
you're the um
you're the very helpful
scholarly kind of vice principal guy a
great way to find this out is to
you you know when you have your classes
or when you're when you're doing
something online ask somebody ask them
to write down on the chat
perceptively when you see me what do you
see
and that might help you find a through
line too it might help you find that you
know when people started coming up to me
and said you remind me of george carlin
you remind me of jerry seinfeld you
remind me of johnny carson
i kind of knew
that first of all i was driven i started
emulating seinfeld when i was first
started
until he made fun of me and then um i
stopped doing that but that was my way
of finding
you know that was i hid behind that to
sort of get up on stage if i failed i
didn't fail jerry seinfeld failed
the character i was emulating kind of
failed it's almost like doing cover
music cover band music oh that you were
that deep into seinfeld you were just
like basically emulating wendy's
emulating his voice like i had my own
jokes but i'd emulate sort of his voice
and his style and his observational
qualities of nuance and hey you know you
know what you know i saw a sign that
said positively no smoking and a lot of
people did back then like
he was like he was almost like the
template for a lot of comedians back
then yeah right and then when carlin
said take that catharsis i was like oh
my god what a release that was for me
so he made fun of you seinfeld did
ninefold yeah where where were you
i was at the lab factory and i did uh i
did a sign i did my my material but it
and i got great laughs uh telling the
story and uh and i kind of used
kind of the seinfeld technique to walk
it all the way around and bring it back
to a callback and then um they you know
like it made them go wow that was very
playful
and um i got a a a really nice set and
then um
and i had followed one of the comedians
i admired but he bombed that night i
can't remember he's no longer like on
the circuit you know he's no longer
touring he's no longer doing anything
and it's like and i really like the dude
uh i can't remember his name i'll look
it up on the break we're not we don't
have a break see that's the joke the
break what's happening the band jerry
thinks he's an am radio still and it's
like um but he uh
he afterwards i walk i see seinfeld
standing right there at the bar and i go
hi jerry seinfeld he goes whatever
oh cool and i went
oh
and i'm a new yorker so i was like dude
don't get personal
you'll regret it and i was like new york
attitude i thought don't get [ __ ]
personal right right
[Music]
why are you talking to seinfeld that way
dude you know and i that's way back in
the day in my early 20s yeah okay cool
so this has actually been an interesting
topic throughout the series and
it is how does a comedian
build a character or a persona
well that comes you know first of all we
get wrapped up in that right and one of
the problems is if we get wrapped up in
that
sometimes they could paralyze us when
we're just starting to learn learn how
to write jokes
right so people say it takes 10 years to
find a persona i said really ask joel he
got up there after four and was like hey
i found my brand no it's not right so
it's like we don't know yet we're
evolving and when we our first flight
five to seven years is trying to learn
how to write a joke so that's why a lot
of people get stuck on
their persona my
persona came kind of early
with um
most of us have a cynical approach to
comedy because we're really we prove
things wrong we like to take perceived
statements of authority and prove them
wrong right we like to look at something
go yeah well here's the mistake in that
like if i say you know whatever happens
in vegas stays in vegas
and you're like what yeah unless it gets
stuck in your crotch here or tell that
to your bank account or whatever it's
like it doesn't always get stuck in
vegas so we try to prove these things
wrong these perceived statements of
authority so it's like so we all have a
cynical approach that's one level of our
of our being um you could be analytical
you could be um ultra perceptive you
could be um like you know even after
whitney was on on this
getting popular she hadn't really found
her voice which is now super independent
woman
you know i don't need this i don't need
a man you know and you feel that in her
roseanne roseanne
here's an exercise to find help you
identify with your persona
take some cliches and do cliche
reformations now cliches cliches are are
statements that everybody knows the
ending to you know uh when in rome do as
the romans a penny saved as a penny
earned my mother used to say the best
way to man's heart is through his
stomach right we know those so roseanne
had this cliche reformation that kind of
defined her voice
and her attitude it's like my mother
said the best way to man's stomach is
the best way to a man's heart is through
his stomach and she goes i think the
best way to man's heart is straight
through his chest
that defined her that joke made her
famous that branded her she's like i've
done this
i'm not doing any more i don't need a
man that was her sort of sassy
relationships attitude and that kind of
like blew up that was like her thing and
and that joke that cliche reformation
joke that she did as simple as it may
seem and most great jokes are very
simple
we think we're supposed to be complex
and interesting and it's like in club
super clever but that's when we lose the
audience if we're just like simple like
jesus [ __ ] like simple reverses but
then he adds sort of like how can i edge
this up a bit or add a little extra
mischief and darkness because because he
realized that's the one those are the
ones the audience was really laughing at
you know um
and but they're like almost simple
reverses all the time he has a setup and
also is like what are they expecting i'm
gonna go the opposite way and then
um
you know brian kiley a masterful joke
writer too who is like the head
monologue writer for conan o'brien he's
so good at that as well
um but um
and that kind of his voice is a little
um
he's like always the jokes are always on
him he's like i'm just trying to he
shrugs a lot i'm just trying to
just trying to get from point a to point
b and
stuff keeps happening you know and
that's his thing the thing is is his
emotional spectrum was about this vast
and so i said he'll never be famous
famous
even though his jokes are amazing
because
it's generic
where stephen wright didn't have a real
vast emotional spectrum but his comedy
was so thoughtful so thinking it really
got our brains involved and we were
trying to solve the puzzle with him you
know so that's what attracted us there
and his nuance of being almost like oh
my brain is so tired i can't even
you know and he'd be like uh i spilled
spot remover on my dog
now it's gone
that's that's you made a
few good points there first off some
people are like what's my persona and
it's like well first figure out how to
write a joke
like figure out how to write jokes first
and then like let your persona come
organically through your ability to
write jokes that are personal
and then also asking people perceptively
what do you think of when you see me
and then maybe have cliches and then
reform them
in your own personal style and just see
what comes out of that yeah so the
cliche reformation starts to help you
identify a point of view
and then once you start to go oh this is
how i think
oh okay so you can start to build on
that now don't be so eager to chase this
god this persona sometimes it's fun to
just experiment with the persona and
make a discovery um and sometimes like
like look at jim gaffigan he's got that
little sort of voice of consciousness
that happens all the time i used to do
that because i used to worry about the
older women or the women in the audience
worried about that i was doing uh
something sexual or something dirty or
naughty and especially if i was doing an
older crowd and be like she's a woman i
always felt like the older women women
might have been judging me so i've been
like every time i do a joke that might
he's always referencing something about
his dick you know and i beat them to the
punch and then i heard gavin and i go
gaffigan kind of does that so i'm going
to leave that alone yeah and then find a
different voice and i had this
voice i used to do was a bit of a stoner
voice based on this guy i knew in high
school named brian stark and be like
whoa no way dude check that out and he
became a whole separate character
um by himself and i wound up opening for
me
as this character
and then i take off the wig and it was
like a stoner dude nobody
knew that it was me
and i'd get up and do this character for
30 minutes then the amc would come up
for three minutes i'd change into a
blazer black shirt and come back up you
know with the bald head and go hey how
about a hand for charlie stone ladies
and gentlemen isn't he funny yes and
they'd be like every i might get a
standing ovation
and they'd be like where's charlie stone
we want to hang out with charlie stone i
go [ __ ] charlie stone
tony clifton huh right yes that was my
tony clifton and it was so fun to do
that but exhausting at the same time but
i realized they loved the the refined
character
that charlie stone brought and he had a
unique point of view man everything was
like
you know it's like i remember i i took i
was in philosophy
and this yeah i took my midterm and i
brought it to the instructor and he was
like um
jerry
because that's my name you'd be like
jerry
you know you forgot to turn in your
final paper
so i'm going to give you a b i said well
this is philosophy critical thought
right he's like that's right i go i did
that paper in my mind
he gave you know what i got
b-minus
so it's like
and people were laughing at now the
character delivery the joke is not on
the page am i looking to go what
but the character delivering the joke is
what made that joke come alive so
sometimes the character point of view is
so important to make that joke work i
think i just i just get impatient jerry
like i'm 11 years in i'm like i i keep
and these are things i tell people to
only worry about what you can control
and then i still i hit moments where i'm
like
why not me
where's my fame like and i love and i i
i'm so grateful for where my career is
at and that the hot breath verse exists
and i wouldn't want any other way but i
think i still as a comedian working
aspiring still have to fight those of
like okay what's my character how can i
brand myself what is my sitcom like
i still have to like battle these
especially now that i released a special
and i'm like okay what's chapter two of
my career but it's not like what you're
saying also is just
a lot of repetition trial and error
paying attention to what people respond
to and start to build it over time it's
not like a light bulb and sometimes it's
something else that somebody else sees
right that you can't see because you're
just too close so that's why you ask
people what do you see when you see me
and be honest like or sometimes you have
to write down write down your top 10
most critical flaws
i try to please too much i'm always
trying to please too much
and it's like i try to like i'm the
peacemaker at my in my house or i'm you
know um
if i need to complain if you know you're
the opposite of a karen
a karen would have no problem going i
need to talk to the manager you'd be
like yeah honey let's just let it go
right yeah like a beta man make waves
you know
that could be a part of maybe who you
are and it's like once you start to find
that it's like i know um i'm pretty
confident with who i am right so so now
i can explore other characters too and
maybe in the exploration of other
characters i find another little nuance
i can add to my main character george
burns went through eight you know eight
basically iterations of who george burns
is before he found george burns oh okay
so it's like it's like sometimes you'll
evolve and then at some point you all of
a sudden just clicks usually it's about
12 years in so you've got about 24
months joel cool allison you're going to
go i'm superman i didn't know this
that's kind of an interesting thing
because like one other person we've
talked to actually said the same thing
you did like talk to people and like who
do i look like and so actually i put
that to the test which and
talking to seven different strangers
five of them said you look like a dj
like you look like you belong and read i
don't that's just because i'm ugly but
you know it's like you look like a radio
guy basically they say you got a face
for radio
one person said you look like the sun
like you could be related to wolfman
jack so it was like dj dj mike so how do
i put that onto a stage
like that so that's my next big thing is
like okay how do i how do you put that
into
stand-up it was like yeah what are the
traits of us dj like
lazy are you stoner pushover like
aiming for the middle like like johnny
fever from wkrp so you know i think also
one way to find uh what i tell students
sometimes is like who are your favorite
comics
those people resonate you with you for a
reason
because there's this part of you in them
where there's a part of them in you i
was like they think the way you do or
they have the same sort of reactions to
things that you do
and it's like
um some like look at john mulaney
john mulaney is just john mullaney yeah
you know he brings all his
idiosyncrasies up there
and he talks about his drug addiction
and his rehab and then winds up checking
into rehab shortly after
that's right that's when he's still
flawed and he still goes through his
like he's going through his journey and
failures and
successes and he's up there talking
about him on stage
that's quite funny because my favorite
is actually like all-time favorite is
actually craig ferguson like
and i just realized i just realized like
a few months ago that he actually had a
completely different character at one
point oh bing hitler being hitler yeah
wow which was like amazing um so yeah so
we have a few more questions uh sandy
asks you rapid fire here yeah
how do you react to uh your joke without
seeming um
contrived or announcing to your audience
here is a joke
that's a great question because um
one of the things that drove me crazy on
on uh tonight's show was like jay leno
would often go oh here's another one
like stop telling people it's a [ __ ]
joke man you take the surprise out of it
we know you're he goes well you know
everybody knows where we do the
monologue yeah well yeah but johnny
carson used to get up there on that
stage hit that star and go i read this
uh story uh in the newspaper out of
minnesota
and all of a sudden you're in the story
with him
and then he has a punch line at the end
when it's a story and we think it's a
story and olson you hit a punch line
despite the fact that we know that
you're on that star in that instant
we're not thinking about that we're in
the story with you we don't take a
moment to go oh yeah this is monologue
so this will probably be a joke because
we don't have the capability to
multitask we think we do but we don't
and i i know that because my wife was
like hey when you're down on me play
with my nipples like oh now you think i
can multitask no but um
sorry did i throw in the dirty one there
wife was that
dirty how does he do that
so what i do sometimes is i try to make
sure it's a conversation oh [ __ ] i
forgot to tell you guys um
sometimes that little trick
coaxes me to get in the real moment so
back when i started i would do something
like that oh [ __ ] i forgot to tell you
guys i was on the driving here and then
i got out of the car so you had to walk
that block you know the blocks like hey
could you get a parking lot it's like
three blocks here
and now it's like i'm in a conversation
it's the moments are happening right
here and i'll be like um and this guy's
playing the car rolls by playing this
old school rep anybody remember the song
was like don't want no short dick man
and it's got playing at like you know 80
decibels so the whole world can hear it
you know how embarrassing is that don't
want no short dick men they actually use
those words don't want no short dick men
how embarrassing is that for me
i'm native american we carried our
spears it didn't come as part of the
package
some comics telegraph it at the end
though they'll like say the punch line
and almost have like a tada there it is
you know what i mean like i think i'm
taking judy carter's course
say what they took judy carter's course
because i where i put i try to go to
everybody's course say hey man maybe
there's a light bulb switch that comes
on and judy said this to a class one
time she was like you know sometimes
i'll tell a joke and you know i'll kind
of let the audience know that that's the
punchline i'll go
so that could become a habit
that's magic don't do ta-da
how do you iron it out
that means your punch line isn't strong
enough yeah exactly yeah so that's and i
think that's something sandy was asking
for like her own personal sets is like
sometimes she will like telegraph like
say it and kind of is it just being
aware of it and then being like okay
this set i'm going to work on not doing
that you hit the nail on the head being
aware of it it's not only being aware of
it it's also being aware of what am i
using to try to get the laugh here
like at the end like one one of this one
of guys that came to me from you he said
here's a here's the last joke i want to
share with you
and um
he's like um and i and i'm not sure why
it's funny
and maybe it isn't but and it was very
funny i said oh yeah it's it's
incongruity you're doing an associative
joke between these two ideas here
and i said and you just fell upon but
now you know it
now i would take that joke and then make
it a template
and that joke is now a template for
other future jokes that are falling into
this charac
category so i know if i have two
dissimilar ideas converging i'm going to
take i'll be able to play those two
dissimilar ideas
right so it's like um there's that uh
the exercises like when you said one
word rain
and remember mitt came to me with that
he said i'm struggling with this one
word on the right ten
and i said oh rain so what else can rain
be
right rain can be so that's one word
it's really hard rain precipitation what
is the definition of rain what if rain
was opposite of what we're thinking of
it is rain could also be the name of a
stripper
right so it's like you know it was like
you know sometimes she let me snort coke
off her ass then when it was rain with a
chance of snow
right and all of a sudden because ask
the questions ask the questions ask the
questions yeah remember the setup is not
to be necessarily be funny it's just to
convey information so the moment you
convey information
and then you're taking that information
and then spinning it in a different way
from what they're perceiving you're
saying then that's the the joke comes
from the information and then we're
leading them somewhere you know trying
to teach my daughter how to tie her
shoes which is weird because she's 22.
and she's like um dad i can't dad i
can't so how many times have i told you
not to use that word i am not your dad
no yeah now i know i'm using ambivalence
for that final punch right it's like you
don't want to say that to a kid that
could [ __ ] him up she's in jail but um
when you're saying i know i'm using
ambivalence so i'm going to deliver it a
certain way it's the same sort of
technique as you know you say uh my son
who is in jersey just came out of the
closet it's gay oh esther your son lives
in jersey um
you know we're supposed to be excited
about the or worried about is what are
you gonna do he's gay what are you gonna
do well that's the one we're focused on
instead we go to the jersey thing my dad
who lives in bakersfield was just
diagnosed with stage four colon cancer i
know it's horrible randy lives in
bakersfield who wants to be there so
it's almost like believe sandy should
just believe in her joke more and being
aware of it and also believing it's
funny without that little extra hitch
and it'll start to kind of work its way
out yeah deliver it as a conversation
and if you know what you're doing
you know you can have fun with that so
if you have it as you just make it a
conversation just like re get in touch
with that energy that you have when
you're at a party
and you're having a conversation and
then try to work your jokes that way
that's one that's one way to do it i
like to take that joke and then talk
about it like it's like
like right off the top of my head it's
rehearsed spontaneity as david letterman
used to call it rehearsed spontaneity
because i remember going to a letterman
rehearsal and then staying for the
taping letterman rehearsal he was like
oh and uh paul i almost forgot um
make sure we
and you get to that segment in the
taping and he's like oh and uh paul um
i go that's planned
like i was full right
and uh
yeah go ahead buddy yeah bobby asks what
does surprise represent in the teaser
method is it the left turn
could be the left turn a left turn is
would be a reverse
right like when i said i'm trying to
teach my daughter how to tie her shoes
or that simple one i have a
nine-year-old
i have a nine-year-old girl and we're
thinking oh he said he said i have a
nine-year-old daughter no i didn't say
that i said i have a nine-year-old girl
right but they're implying or they're
assuming a nine-year-old daughter so if
i say have a nine-year-old girl in my
basement that could be the left turn
right so it's a reverse that's a very
specific technique right you lead them
to a very explicit assumption
or the one was like you know i woke up
at the hotel room uh the silver legacy
uh my first night working there and the
housekeeper is seven in the morning
banging on the door just banging finally
had to get up and let her out she was
relentless right we have an expectation
that's created and we shattered that
expectation
so that's a reverse that's that left
turn not all jokes have a left turn you
don't need a left turn on every one of
your jokes if i do an incongruity joke
like when these guys in this podcast
called me and they tried to like oh you
said you can take any logical grouping
of words and make it funny i didn't say
it i said you should believe that
because there are logical groupings of
words on my computer i haven't succeeded
with yet but if i i tell that to
students so they don't run away from a
straight line because it's not already
funny but if you have so they go we're
going to give you a random joke and see
if you can do something with this it's
like sort of like the right ten club but
they're trying to make me look like an
idiot
and uh rather than help me right and i
could sense their attitude like let's
try it let's see if it could work man i
might fail miserably right here on on
your will listen to podcast right
so they were like now we're just random
thing we just got this out of the pa
right out of the internet it said a new
study
uh a review said that um a lego has
become a more popular has over has beat
ferrari as the world's most popular
brand
lego has beat ferrari as the world's
most popular brand the first thing i'm
thinking is like attitude that's
ridiculous
lego
over ferrari
and then i do a quick listing technique
ferrari red
uh convertible
hot model
right and that's what came into my head
that's that's part of the list that when
i was thinking about ferrari and so he
goes like a new study now we're making
fun of the study and we're calling the
study ridiculous that's the angle
so i go lego has replaced ferrari as the
world's most popular brand
really lego replays ferrari it's like
yeah yeah try try [ __ ] a supermodel
after showing her your legos
the attitude gets to the joke surprise
and the joke is now i'm playing the
emotional through line through the end
of the joke which is another trick to it
for that to answer that question play
the play the emotion through the joke
don't play the gag
so mario asked can you give an example
of a configurational
trigger
yeah mitch hedberg stephen wright
uh mitch hedberg i'm staying at a hotel
i can't tell you the name but it has two
trees
yeah yeah yeah right and people go
doubletree yeah yeah yeah i got it we
love to be able to solve the puzzle
right it's like you know be like uh
steven wright would be like you know
there's this light switch in my house it
doesn't do anything every time i walk
past it i flick it on i flick it off i
flick it on i flick it off about six
months later i got a letter from a lady
in germany saying cut it out
oh i get it you know it's like
that moment
or sometimes don't finish the ending
right i have a student um
he was when he first came to me he was
overweight had social anxiety so his
therapist said take a comedy class and
he did and great guy and you know he was
like so had such anxiety he would shine
when he took the stage because he was
already sweating you know had that
anxiety sweat going on and he had a joke
he says i live he says and we told him
to just be just tell the truth about you
what just tell the truth and he was like
i'm gay i live in west hollywood it's
like it's really hard to date in west
hollywood because all the guys are tan
and chiseled and i'm
well like i said i'm it's hard to date
in west hollywood
he doesn't explain what he is we see
what he is yeah so the audience laughs
at the fact that he didn't even have to
explain it it's their their involvement
in the configuration of it makes them
laugh harder because they're like yeah
we got it now if they have to configure
too much
if there's more than like two seconds it
diminishes the laugh and will sometimes
diminish the left to zero so it had they
have to be able to figure it out pretty
quickly a second and a half you know or
something like that cool
yeah bo we got any more
um somebody asks where is it at davida
asked uh oh she stated you have to have
thick skin to be a comedian but at what
age
would you encourage a child who has
stand-up potential this is actually
interesting because today my principal
said we have a lot of students who love
writing jokes maybe you can teach them
how to
structure it and i just it's perfect
timing bow as well because i just did a
12 year old's podcast today not to brag
it's called the chatting comedian and um
he asked me to be on his show and so
he's been doing a podcast an interview
comedy interview podcast and he's 12.
it's very cool awesome yeah
well 12 is a good is a good range right
so that's when we start to make fun of
our friends and
we get
we're able to take the insults sort of
the ranks we get ranked out by our
friends and we're cool with that because
we know it's fun and games eight nine
and ten
they're still crying because they called
me you know they called me uh of clubs
you know what i'm saying and now when
you get like when you get to 12 you're
able to you get it now and also keep in
mind
i've i've coached i had a student of
mine she had 11 kids
right so um
many of them surrogates but she brought
the kids to do a comedy class over the
summer and so we'd meet one day a week
for about five weeks and then we're
putting on a talent show at her house
and she's uh married to a
multi-multi-millionaire so that was
their thing and i thought oh cutest
thing ever
she would work with them then i would
work with them and we they wound up
putting on a really good talent show and
i was helping them take their kind of
nuanced ideas and their nuanced jokes
based on what are their quirks
individual quirks about them and make
turn them into jokes so
they whether they knew it was funny or
not was a different story but they knew
they were getting a laugh um so that's
like remember we used to watch looney
tunes bugs bunny some of those jokes
when we were kids didn't make any sense
my parents were laughing but i'd be like
huh how's that funny
they don't understand irony at that at
that age eight you know that young age
12 you begin to get it you begin to see
it when you're 15 16 you start
developing the the the ability for
complex thought and critical thinking
when you're 24
you don't even you barely have a fully
developed frontal cortex
so
so in those age that 12 year old is is
really good age to start you know and
then 14 you'll start really hitting a
good stride it's like when chappelle
started like 14 eddie murphy started at
like 14 but eddie murphy started at 14
because he was basically reciting
richard pryor's and i think bill cosby's
routines
and then finally at 19 when everybody
goes oh my god he's amazing other
comments are going okay you got to stop
doing richard pryor's routine he's like
why he said because that's his material
he didn't even know he was like i didn't
know that i thought it was everybody's
material yeah so how would you teach and
how would beau and i would imagine you
know i'd be happy to help bo with this
too but like it's not like you're you're
gonna take them through the like nine
comedy triggers or things like how do
you really kind of boil it down to teach
kids the essentials
well it's not about what i would do is
say it's not about being funny it's
about telling you know just you know
making observations honest observations
starting with honest observations and
basic facts about you my mother always
says
um i'm gonna kick him with a sundown
shine
it's like so what does she mean by that
oh you're gonna kick him in the butt
right right okay that's what we know
right that's we know that phrase it
means i'm gonna kick him with the sun
gentle shine i'm gonna kick him in the
butt so where else doesn't the sun shine
seattle
oh yeah right in the closet you know
yeah like um it's like um so my mother
always says i'm gonna kick them where
the sun don't shine i'll be like i was
like you're gonna kick him in seattle
so simple truth jokes are great for kids
um study the riddles learning riddle
writing is actually learning to write
jokes backwards
you're coming up with the punch line
first
write 10.
that's right the punch word or the punch
line that's right
and then writing the joke finding the
joke behind it so sometimes those um um
what we call uh collocations
we that's groupings of words we see
together a lot you know it's like uh
carefully selected
you know we only use carefully selected
prime beef as opposed to
[Music]
you know
not carefully selected as opposed to
like frivolously selected we don't we
don't use prime beef we use roadkill you
know
we don't it's like carefully so we
always have so if you look up
collocations there's a lot of those
combination phrases that don't belong
together we don't need that you know
it's like we're going to use all
available assets to find this missing
person
and some uh some unavailable assets
you know or whatever it's like the
phrasing
with those implications and the
assumption of what those words mean are
so strong we just default okay yeah that
sounds right instead of really looking
at it go wait a second all available
assets when i was 12 years old
this is why i thought 12 was a good age
bo
when i was 12 years old
i went to the uh i went to the post
office with my dad
and this is in new york and on the right
above the handle of the post office door
it said no dogs allowed except seeing
eye dogs and i said dad what's a seeing
eye dog and he said that's a dog that
helps blind people to get around
and i said that doesn't make sense
is dog gonna read this sign
and i go
who's the sign for then and then
then gary shandling did the joke like in
like 1976 or something like that i was
like hey wait a second my dad was like
you did that joke when you were 12. i go
what i said oh i remember that that sign
it never forget that sign
and i was like oh neat so i did a joke i
didn't know i did a joke i was just
asking a question
you know awesome that's that that's
great because actually like with right
the school i work at we have a news
broadcast every single day and there's a
joke segment and
so a lot of students are sending in
jokes and trying to learn how to write
them and so now my new principal's like
here here's a good idea i want you to
actually mentor these kids because
they may have potential one day and may
want to choose it and
looking at the conversation we had is
like hey i never knew at you know 18
that hey i love comedy but i didn't know
how to get there never thought about it
so that's very helpful yeah i think one
of the best things to start with would
be word play double entendre right like
we often misunderstand the meaning of
for a word um
and uh i'm uh and
then um
simple truth jokes now simple truth
jokes
is like you hear a lot of times in
in lyrics or in uh sonnets or in um
scripture very symbolic
words right very poetic
words and
they're implied they're they're used to
imply something
but they're not
explicitly
the words if it the explicit meaning of
a word could be totally different
and like for example you ever listen to
the it's a small world song it's a world
of joy it's a world of tears it's a
world of hope it's a world of fears
joy hope tears fears isn't this a song
about being bipolar
[Laughter]
what's the simple truth of it
listen to like spring springsteen bruce
springsteen hey little girl that's your
daddy home did he go and leave you all
alone
i got a bad desire
oh
pedo fire really
at what point did springsteen become a
pedophile that's what i want to know
we never really think about what the
words mean we're just buying the concept
that's being that's being shared with us
in a poetic way or whatever so those two
little tricks work well with kids like
the double entendre and double entendre
is like a main go-to in sitcom and in
commercial writing
it's like especially with kids that are
still in that precipice of 10 to 12 they
still love those little fun jokes and
it's like um like uh uh if you go like
look at the commercial for discover the
credit card right the guy's like
holding a frog in his hand he's on the
phone discover yes you guys have frog
insurance right yes we have fraud
insurance and there's a split screen and
they're doing the play on fraud and frog
now if you were to do that at a comedy
club as an adult people would go hack
right which i hate there's nothing
that's hacked it's just it's like it's
just been overdone but if you can find a
new punch line to a com or to a to a
premise that's been done a bazillion
times that's genius right and like
something we've never heard before wow
right that's so nev hack kills
creativity so does the word no so it's
like they're like frog fraud fraud frog
he goes like we're on the same page yeah
totally on the same page at discovery
commercial want a clio
and there's a student i teach and i was
telling him about this and he was like
jerry i wrote that commercial
what dave you wrote that commercial yeah
you know i've been in advertising right
you never shared that with me at all wow
i'm just helping you with your stand up
he goes yeah here's my here's my page
and i go to his page and look at all
these commercials i go you did this one
too he goes uh he goes yeah but i love
you he's like that word play on the
discovery he goes i learned that in your
two-day workshop
charlie barron's on here i had char
after we did our our second interview
with you you told us about charlie and i
ended up having charlie on the podcast
too he's great that's totally great
great guy
he figured it out yeah and who happened
for his uh
for his success i mean what he said we
were like in class he said how do you
break through i said do a youtube video
i have a channel have a specific
character and a character niche and just
uh you can start with delivering the
news for a minute and a half or three
never a minute make it go with the three
minutes when you start
and
i don't know whether he remembered that
or whether it sunk went to the back of
his head and he's going through he
started when i found out when i found
out he had a youtube channel he already
had 77 000 subscribers
and then they found out he booked a show
at flappers in the main room on a
saturday at four o'clock and sold it out
yeah and i bought tickets and i got you
know i bought tickets before it sold out
of course i you know because i told them
my tech i emailed them and said hey man
i'm coming to see your show he goes hey
i'll get you in i said no you're worth
buying the tickets for dude
believe that start believing that now
right so i'm happy to buy a ticket for
you that's [ __ ] great so excited
right so i go there sold it out at four
o'clock in the afternoon who does that
charlie behrens who established this
huge fan base and only 77 000
subscribers at the time now he has like
350 000 or more right so he's going to
be booking tours selling out rooms based
on that subscriber base because
man i saw the show the jokes aren't
incredible but they're good because the
character character yeah and this and
the people that come to see him are his
fans man
and they buy everything
you know you could he'd sell his merch
that way he can scale his his
appearances and plus he gives them value
too because he got this thing signed by
charlie parents he's our guy managed to
walk a minute yeah and you you have fans
uh you have fans in here uh jerry joel
brills um says hello os morris sent me a
message yeah great guys yeah oz os
morris told me to let you know hello as
well while you were on here this is uh
yeah ours is terrific man
and um i was using my late night club
and my late night writing class
yeah he was like boy he picked up on the
nuances you could tell he was practicing
because every week he came back and his
material got sharper and tighter and he
was like some of those jokes would have
rivaled some guy's jokes that i worked
with you know you know what you're like
oh that's a great joke dude yeah he's in
the right king club like every day yeah
he's in there he's in there steady uh bo
what do you think maybe one more
question
uh
i saw i saw a good one from ben
webb
about teaching comedy
ben whip
uh
all right i was like i was skeptical
about that one but okay
all right question on a scale of one to
greg dean how much do you love teaching
comedy
how much do i love teaching comedy i
guess yeah i guess
i'm like gwen the great d which is the
higher what's the it's like i i i tell
you what i
i fell in love with it by accident
because i didn't know i was already
doing it and i was just helping guys you
know when i was do i used to go to open
mics listen to guys work and i'd write
down tags and toppers for them and just
hand them to them i said hey if you if
you find that funny hey feel free to use
it they're like wow i can use that
and so that's what i was doing and then
when i started it's like
since some of my students really helped
me teach because they'd be like how did
you get there how what are the steps you
used to get there and it made me have to
think of what i was using rather than
just intuitiveness or my instinct over
the years i had really had to come up
with what was my mental process and by
working harder it made me a little bit
of a better teacher because now i
couldn't i didn't just have to punch up
somebody's joke i could show them how to
get there so that now they can do it you
know teach somebody to fish that sort of
thing um
and um so what a great great dean i
[ __ ] love it uh and again i don't i
don't i don't disparage greg or any
other teacher that's trying to teach
people greg's been doing it for 40 years
so
um you know i'm a fan of his even though
he tried to sue me
oh god
yeah when i first started to teach
comedy i was like um you know comedy is
basically the one definition of a joke
the original definition of a joke of two
dissimilar ideas converging and that was
on my youth that first youtube video uh
i did about tiger woods is my first
video that i ever put out there and he
says i'm going to sue you i go for what
he goes chuck's the position of two
contrasting ideas is mine i go you know
who really originally came up with that
greg aristotle
so unless you're 2001 year old
then uh you know he came up with a first
then a man named james beatty a scottish
philosopher in 1473 recoined the phrase
and recoined the definition so it's like
uh i said besides it's a concept you
can't patent a concept greg you know
it's like otherwise um um the uh
everybody would be paying forward
for the internal combustion engine you
know uh so it's like because they
invented it so it's like
and it's like you
i didn't you gonna sue me for what he
goes i didn't teach you company so you
could teach it
and i go i think the pills they have you
want are really hurting your
your thought process greg we're not in
competition brother
amen we should energize it would make it
so much better because you know what
there was a student of mine who went to
him and something he said made her get
the reverse that she wasn't getting when
i was saying it
is that something against me no it's a
[ __ ] win man oh i'm so happy and she
started writing good reverses whatever
he said worked great by all means you
don't become a doctor by going to one
teacher and people say oh you can't
teach tal your comedy you either got it
or don't really what babies are popping
out of the womb going hey is this thing
on yeah you call that a birth canal
you know they're not doing it you learn
through exposure and experience and if
you can consolidate that exposure
experience and give people actual tools
and reasons people laugh
they don't laugh randomly man
they laugh for a reason now if you can
identify that reason
you know you can start writing jokes
like chappelle knows that he when he
does that he's i'm going to tell you the
punch line
and then i'm going to do the joke and
you're still going to laugh yeah
and what he did basically kind of the
same thing it's like riddle writing
he basically told us the punchline then
tells the story and then that becomes a
callback now so good and it's like
coincidentally it fit in a totally
different story in a different situation
that same phrase kicked her in the [ __ ]
it's incredible our 12 year old's
listening we're in trouble right like
that was that was on the train and clear
us up at this point right yes we're not
well let's not cancel coralie on this we
start a hashtag cancel courtly did you
hear him on hot breath yeah so he and
what he did was here's what's great
about chappelle chappelle knew
that he had to really make this woman a
big antagonist
for him to get away with that phrase or
that action that he said that happened
right and he made a really bad person a
really bad antagonist so then when he
did that
it worked
you know you can't attack a woman
without there being a reason right so if
like that's what if i'm doing jokes
about my ex i always say my ex who
cheated on me yeah you know i actually
cheated on me called me on halloween
said jerry i don't know what to pretend
to be for halloween i said well why
don't you just dress normally and
pretend you're in a committed
relationship
now the audience feels oh we need the
and they're not when you set up the
antagonist
they're rooting for you to win
right but the tack has to be
proportional you know
sullivan the same comic who earlier said
lazy childbirth um she said i found you
through steve martin's master class and
then i found father joel
so
we're there's there's a funnel to both
of us here
listen hear that steve martin's master
class refers people to my 13 comedy
structures
my students i said yeah hey jerry you
heard that steve martin has a master
class out should i get it [ __ ] yeah he's
a legend yeah right he's a living legend
i would absolutely get that course then
they were coming back jerry i got the
course like you said he refers people to
your 13 comedy structures so i got a
refund
don't get a refund you're hearing steve
martin talk about comedy it's worth the
99 fox idiots come on come on i mean
i've listened to some of it it's really
good it really is gives you insights and
viewpoints and
and they're like the structures are just
one one element of it
you know that's but it's like now but it
gives you a tool oh i can write a
reverse today i can write incongruities
today i can write some uh uh some
observational stuff today i can uh write
a paradox i can write irony it doesn't
have to have that left turn it just has
to have irony oh my god what a
coincidence what you know that's true so
it's like that's where that joke comes
from is like is from the irony oh i
didn't know that
you know
irony and uh let's say paradox is
awesome like when jerry seinfeld says he
says it's on talk funny on that that hbo
you know round table
he said you know you need to go deeper
with your jokes right joe said that you
need to go deeper with the jokes but
then you look at everybody starts
thinking deep
i got to be deep got to be deep
it's like um
sometimes just the paradox or the irony
is what makes it deep
so it's like jerry seinfeld's subject
matter is not deep
c.k subject matter is not deep or
original he's talking about the same
[ __ ] we're all living you know marriage
kids
the struggles we all go through his
approach his unique points of view
is the way he sees it is what makes it
deep the paradox or the like seinfeld
does that joke we refer to distance in
time
we'll be like how far is it to the store
about 15 minutes doesn't work the other
way around at all what time do you get
off work about five miles
that's not deep
it's just a paradox they go oh [ __ ] i
never thought about it that way that's
so true
so it's like that's where like sometimes
deeper
can create creative paralysis
because we're trying to be too original
you know it's like instead of just going
all right let me see if i can put this
joke in the form of a paradox
and then that makes the brain do a
little dance between the both
hemispheres there and we go oh
that works study paradox paradox will
you know it's just simple things like
you know why do they call it a boxing
ring when it's square
you know it's the they come from
ponderables if you like red
10 or 20 ponderables that you download
from the internet and you're not in a
funny mood you're going to be in a funny
mood after that you're going to be in a
creative ponderable mood you know if you
drove your car the speed of sound could
you hear your stereo
yes just the front speakers but not the
back
you know people go oh
and that's that's deep to them oh that's
deep
let's let's land this plane here uh
sullivan said she read the book like the
bible i don't know if that means she
read it they went did other something
else like send
yeah exactly
somebody else over
you know she read the book and then said
we got to keep those illegal immigrants
out of our country
and get around people brown people and
get me a gun
right yeah and get me a gun right
i love that see look at you guys you
took simple truth
she read the book like a bible and you
started making fun
basically using associations to the but
what what do other people do that read
the bible or say that say they read the
bible they don't listen to it right yeah
and then she sent it and he did the
look i've read it twice and i kind of
need to read it a third time and just
like i read the bible now i just use it
for
or rolling exorcisms
it's perfect paper right that's i
remember a kid in middle school told me
that and it's i've always remembered
that for some reason
i'm smoking matthew 6'5 yeah it's lit
burning like the hypocrites and praying
the street corners in the synagogues to
be seen of man but praying private in
thy closet and thou shalt be rewarded
openly
i'm a philosopher
[Laughter]
you guys are so much fun
dude every time every time we connect we
got yeah we got to figure out yeah we
got to keep doing more together and keep
building this energy there's so much
overlap like i can't i've lost count of
the amount of people who are like i
found you through jerry corley or you
and jerry like there's just so many
there's just so much overlap i i don't
know why like we'll have to figure out
more ways to combine forces for good
without a doubt man without a doubt
because it does work and it also teaches
a lesson not only to other comics that
you don't have to shy away from it you
can be at an open mic and laugh at
somebody else's joke and it doesn't take
anything away from you yeah it doesn't
make you less funny if you're out there
going oh dude that's great
it doesn't make you less funny yep it
just makes you supportive of other
comedians and other artists and trust me
this comes back in a big way later on
it's a small business and be nice to
everybody on the way up you meet the
same people on the way down unless
you're betty white because there's no
way down you just stay up there
she's never not been a star but that
also means you know why she's so nice to
everybody right that also means when
we're at the open mics we should pay
attention to one one another than
worrying about our own [ __ ]
do your homework at home
yeah that's what i'm worried i'm i'm
hoping that as comedy scenes open back
up like i'm hoping members of the hot
breath verse who have been absorbing
this positivity in this community and
this support
i'm hoping it starts to seep into the
comedy scenes that people go back to
because we've been online we've been
insulated and it's all been positive
supportive i'm hoping that starts to
seep into the comedy scenes people go
back into because i mean there's enough
for everyone and like like rising tides
raise all boats and it's just the more
supportive we can be
i mean when i started it was just around
people
no but you're so right man it's like
it's like
if positivity breeds positivity yes and
it creates it it actually creates more
opportunities
like if everybody's positive together
and you're in a room and you're sharing
jokes you're sharing ideas you're not
holding back and you're like hey try
this hey try this here's something that
a lot of people don't realize and here's
a little here's a little gift something
you'll never hear in any comedy class or
in any book nobody's talking about it
the difference between a set working and
a set not working when you're doing the
same material could be one thing and
that's in that first set where it worked
you established community
you made people feel like they were a
part of your show with you on a show in
a conversation with your show
the other part the the second part or
maybe didn't work you were trying to
repeat the first night
and rather than really be with the
audience and there's so many different
ways to create community but um uh
what's her name tyler taylor tomlinson
does this brilliant thing at the
beginning i don't think she knows she's
actually doing this on a conscious level
but it is brilliant way of creating
community she walks out there's her
second special and she's blowing up
she's terrific i love her right she
walks out on stage and the audience is
cheering and she's like
and as she does that they cheer more
because they say we're getting a
reaction out of here let's do this some
more right and they cheer more and then
she says wow you guys are great i hope
my ex sees this
and they all go we'll get them let's do
this together yeah
she's got him eating out of the palm of
her hand the rest of the show she just
created community
so it's like think about that how can
you bring them in how can you bring them
in one of my students did she's like she
does hi y'all she gets up there and says
hi y'all and she's dressed stylishly
right so we don't expect hi y'all we you
know she looks like she's a city girl
right so hi y'all and the audience
giggles
and some guy had a weird giggle and
she's got a weird giggle and she's like
you know i'm taking yes you got a great
laugh i'm taking you on the road with me
and the audience applauds that why do
they applaud because you made them feel
accepted you created community and now
they were with her for the rest of the
show they were rooting for her for the
rest of the show the second time she did
that
she forgot to create community she just
went in i'm going to do exactly what i
did last week and she did the jokes but
she forgot to connect
and that's where the audience humans
beings human beings connect through
emotion that's why we want to be
together it's like we we love that
community bring that's where synergy
comes into play synergize with your
audience
boom
that's see that's i gave that away for
free i didn't hold back
you didn't have to go to my book to get
that i'll give away [ __ ] all day because
she's like one clarification we didn't
have to go spend a hundred dollars on a
class when that happened i was just like
really dude a sing do you think not
answering someone's question is going to
make them want to go buy it from you
it was a
they probably would have gone and gotten
you because you're a trusted resource
yeah it was a simple simple question i
think it's like a simple technique
question and it was
i i can't give that away you have to go
take my class give me money but that's
hey you know to each their own and i'm
glad that um jerry was the headliner and
speaking of synergy you just started a
podcast with a member of the hot breath
verse ashley gutermuth you guys started
she is wonderful she's like she actually
co-hosts my a la carte classes
and uh so because you know you need to
sort of regulate the noise sometimes and
turn off the mics if somebody's got a
dog barking or something in the
background and uh she's terrific she is
like she is immersed
and she is like it's not years the years
you put in it's the hours of practice
you put in and she's working on it every
single day she's gonna she's gonna be a
star and she's smart and she's helpful
helps out people like crazy she's just a
really good comedy soul and it's like
the way i talk about it you think i'm
hitting on her but no i'm not messing
with her colonel husband
but she's just such a good person and
it's like um we got to get back to our
podcast you know she might be too busy
to be doing it she got so busy so it's
like that i'll just have to do mine on
my own and then uh you know have to go
hey we're going to be talking to joel
brill and bo next week so those are
we're gonna have a three-way podcast now
we're always co-hosts we're like who's
the co-host we're good
i'm always open to starting another
podcast because i've already got three
information information information
people love it and hey if it helps then
that's positive yes
yeah and and i like that because in the
end comedy wins
yep
preach now we're just yeah now we're
prostitution
um so you're about to ask a question so
where can
oh i was just you were talking about
information and i was going to segue
well where can people get more of your
information like it says they're right
on that thing for more information on
jerry's classes and clinics go to you
guys have a chiron and everything look
at that
and clinics go to
standupcomedyclinic.com
go to standupcomedyclinic.com
that's all i can do i'm not going to
tell you any more information you have
to buy something
if you have a question come to twitter
and ask questions it's like
joke doctor all one word and it's like
people ask me questions all the time but
the good thing is to put it in the feed
because then other people learn as well
it becomes a community it's like
sometimes people ask me questions and
one of the other participants says hey
you mind if i jump in and try to help
sure man every time you teach it helps
you to get better
i and i could say before i even knew hot
birth existed i mean and when i first
found jerry i had put stuff in the
twitter and you've helped me out so and
then of course there's the shitload of
videos you have on youtube that's free
and that's been quite helpful with
repairing jokes or how to deal with
hecklers which is always a big question
i know every new comic has is how do i
deal with this [ __ ] you know yeah
when are you going to start filming
again jerry uh um i might i might uh
probably gonna start next week i'm going
to get a um you know when i the thing is
like habit right i realized how i was
affected by habit and the habit getting
smashed like i had my studio i no longer
have that studio um because i had to
shut it down because the owner of the
studio the landlord uh my lease ran up
right at the end of february last year
when the pandemic was kicking in and he
was like
he'd been trying to get rid of me for a
while because i was locked into a nice
rent uh for five years and i was at the
place ten years and he didn't raise the
rent after five years so i was locked
into a really nice rate then all of a
sudden he wanted to get more money but
instead of just asking me hey i want to
double the the rent because the rents
around the area had the same place was
like three thousand dollars and he was
charging me much less than that so he
was he said but he's like
okay you're terminated you're we're
terminating your occupancy you have to
get out i've got a new tenant i was like
what where's this coming from dude and
it was like um it was the dad that that
was his place he was like 80 now and now
his son was taken over the fiery guy and
he was like um he's now looking to
maximize his profits you know rather
than let's help some people out and he
basically pulled the rug out from under
me and didn't even barely gave me time
to get out of there i was i was down in
florida knocking on doors for joe biden
when they were kicking us kicking me out
and one of my students terry terry s
she's a comedian she's probably done the
right ten as well she's the one that
stepped up and helped me move the [ __ ]
she got a truck and just did everything
for me and i was like you know without
her [ __ ] i don't know what i where i'd
be she's amazing it's like but this is
part of the synergy when you give give
give give and you help help help up help
people are more like hey you need some
help i'll help you with this i said yeah
i'm not even getting home for three days
this guy's just gonna take my [ __ ] out
tomorrow
right yeah that's i was thinking because
like i'll um i'm getting my second
vaccination next week
and i i was planning to make a trip out
to l.a because i have a friend that
lives out there
um and i was like we should synergize
and say yeah man let's do that and i may
be maybe doing a crop of crossover to
teach my classes in person at this new
comedy club called the comedy chateau
um which is one of my students
um actually like i was put out the dream
to people that it's like one day i would
love to buy the comedy store
and um so i put that out there and he
comes to me he's a lawyer he comes up to
me go and say hey jerry and he's got
this very interesting cartoon face right
a great character face he goes jerry you
still want to buy a comedy club i'm
buying this building i'm going to turn
it into a comedy club you want in and my
wife was like no now it's not the time
we still get keith's finishing up law
school we can't put any money into
anything else right now it's like you
got it you know you're the pilot you
drive this plane so um she's actually an
airline pilot so uh uh she uh she put
her foot down i was like nope i said now
i'm gonna make fun of you um
explains the girlfriend right
um
see exactly so she was but i knew yeah
she's right
because that was that was like september
october of 2019 what kicked in
in 2020 a year of no business
on a very expensive piece of land you
know real estate yeah so
but he stayed with it and he kept it he
kept it he's he's been up you know
upgrading the facility and beautiful
restaurant beautiful club and he's he's
uh it's just opened and um so i'm
hopefully going to be able to do some
cooperative crossovers there uh and do
classes there but we'll see you know but
it's still a great club and i'm i'll
help him out any way i can
so maybe we can we can synergize there
and do something that would be fun yeah
that would be fun yeah i'll definitely
um i'll let you know when my plans are
for actually getting out there but i
definitely i'm i got i'm itching man i
gotta i gotta get moving again it's been
so long since i've been like out and
about so i'm excited so all i know is
you said california and i heard home
sweet home
no are you from california where are you
bo so i'm originally from salinas oh
cool right on yeah and uh it's been a
while since i've been home but yeah i
grew up i grew up around all those
lettuce fields and
got my ass kicked by a lot of gangs and
can make fun of it now so you know
actually that's kind of funny i actually
had a school bully
find out i was a comedian and messaged
me and goes please don't ever put me in
a joke
oh yeah all right your jokes
yep that's always fun right
get to make fun of people that end with
a dab have you ever dabbed before jerry
yeah i i don't know you dab this one
and the key is like the the arms have to
be like parallel can you get them
parallel i don't know does it work can
you do that
so real quick sandy does want to know is
jerry going to keep doing online classes
that's a great question because i got
i've got this question with me a la
carte classes people were worried who
would be able who were able to access
the classes
out of this out of state that didn't
live in burbank and i was like
absolutely uh because we're reaching
people around the world with the a la
carte classes yeah and it's like and
it's just so exciting to have somebody
on you know from austria talking to you
and learning something and that's really
yeah so absolutely i'm going to continue
doing those
and i might be adding a new type of um
you know sort of like something i was
thinking about right like wednesdays
it's like i like to take comedians like
uh seinfeld or bill burr or you know um
chris rock and uh or bill hicks and then
um show how what techniques they use to
so write like bill hicks how to write
like bill burr how to write like jerry
seinfeld and show the little tricks and
nuances they use in their structures and
those seem to be i've done three of
those and they seem to be really popular
so i might just make that as in uh
stand-alone
class once a week
just add new comedians
and um
help people identify the the structures
and
techniques they're using to get to
generate their labs it was actually an
idea i had for a podcast the first one i
wanted to do but i've never got off is
like the history of comedy with
comedians and their the way what made
them them basically
so but that's an awesome very
interesting the history is great though
because the history i don't tell
comedians read as many biographies or
autobiography as you can of comedians
you'll find that you they're going they
went through the same stuff that you're
going through yeah so you don't feel so
lost don't feel so alone you're like oh
they went through this if they did it i
can do it yeah
somebody said this is where they'd
usually tell uh jerry this is where
people need a pee break
um yes who said that all right that
might be phyllis or ashley
yeah let's let's let's land the plane i
told my wife seven and at 7 50. i'm on
my first marriage i know jerry said he
did a couple marriages with comedy but
i'm i don't have i'm four years in i
gotta hold on for a little bit
that was good oh it just says facebook
facebook user yeah
they didn't they didn't agree to stream
yards servicing to show their name
that's kind of that's okay that's that
kind of thing gets you kicked off of
twitter
yeah show your name and besides when you
show your name you're synergizing
so um so uh so joke. basically
twitter.com forwardslashjokedoctor or
standupcomedyclinic.com
if you want to directly communicate
twitter's the best way
and it's like like during the holiday i
took a little break from twitter but um
i'm usually on there a lot and trying to
answer questions when i can because i
love doing it just love it i can go down
the rabbit hole with that because it's
super creative it's not just me you're
complaining about oh well yeah
this sucks or like it's like
community it's creative so it's
adds to your writing time
all right awesome so wrap it up let's
wrap it up how do we end this is there
an end button is there do we have a
stinger there is an end button my mouse
is right over it y'all
we give each other the light we get yeah
we give the one minute
y'all this has been the comedy book
series uh hot breath pro talks with
the joke dr jerry corley i am comedian
bo johnson that is comedian uh
joel byers
yes joel byers the hot breath godfather
and we will see you next time peace
peace